women talk about something like empathy
right and you mention that in your
in your email and women are known to be
more empathetic than men
totally fine but women don't care about
a man's struggle they hang out at the
finish line and they pick the winners
right well i care about a man's trouble
and i think a lot of women
i think a lot of women care about a
man's struggle like why wouldn't you i
care about a woman's struggle and i care
about a man's struggle i care about
the struggle like the more i love
somebody the more i care about their
troubles
right but if you see them
disintegrate becoming a loser version
because of bad choices
because of choices because of lifestyle
because of
whatever happens and you have other
options let's say kevin from your sales
department starts hitting on you
maybe steve from accounting looks pretty
good next week and then you have lunch
with them
and there's some interest generated and
a little bit of a spark lights up
and you know the guy at home the ltr the
boyfriend sitting around picking his
nose playing call of duty all day
smoking weed getting fat eating cheetos
with
you know dorito dust on his chin when
you come home kevin from sales is going
to look like a better option than bozo
at home
am i right yes so my boyfriend's not
going to do that
you are not going to do that as a
boyfriend so knowing yourself like you
know yourself you know you're not going
to do that you might [ __ ] up a little
bit but you're not going to do anything
like that
right so why don't you trust your
girlfriend to keep loving you i know but
what you're trying to do irene is you're
is you're trying to take
your interpretation of the sexual
marketplace
of how you view the world and you're
trying to take that and unplug it from
your
firmware and plug it into rich cooper
and say i want you to see things
my way and men don't need to see things
your way
men need to see things their way they
need to understand
what masculinity looks like and how to
view the sexual marketplace so they can
get better results and be admired by the
women that they want to be with
what's the difference between my way and
and like what's disagreeable about what
i said with disability
what is my way i'm not i'm not
disagreeing with you
with with with your belief system i'm
not disagreeing with your worldview
that's a feminine
approach to life and that's what you
should use
men have a different men need to have a
different belief system
if they want to get better results the
problem is as most men today
are plugged into a feminine type of
belief system which gets some crap
results
so the feminine belief system is is
works for women
but it doesn't work well what is it what
is the feminine beliefs is like like
summarize what you're talking about
well i mean you just use the excellent
you know example like you know don't you
want to be like love the way that women
you know love and you love each other in
an unconditional way and blah blah blah
but
you also said in the next breath that if
you stopped chasing excellence and
became a loser you'd probably bounce on
him
but if your girl turns into a blimp if
your girl turns into a blimp you're
probably gonna bounce on her
correct so she also has to do certain
things
but for different reasons women are
beauty objects to men
men are success objects to women okay so
if you totally [ __ ] up the success part
of the equation
the woman will bounce and if she totally
[ __ ] up the beauty part of the equation
then the man will bounce
not always but the clock will click you
know start ticking down to the end of
that
relationship okay but can two people
trust each other to keep doing the right
thing day after day
i think that two people in a
relationship should trust each other
the you know the man should trust the
woman to be a woman and the woman should
trust the man to be a man
if a hot girl walks by with giant tits
he's gonna look at her
yes but who cares that's my point
just like guys should be saying hey if i
stop chasing excellence if i get lazy if
i get fat if i get you know sit around
today all day long playing call of duty
doing nothing with myself
becoming a loser and she leaves me okay
that's the nature of women you know it's
the same thing that's all i'm saying
okay so i feel like well you're not but
you're not quite answering my question
are you well what are you a specific
question my my question
is uh if you keep doing the right thing
day after day
chasing excellence all that stuff why
don't you trust your woman to stay with
you because i trust women to be women
there's there's other reasons why women
leave men but primarily it's because of
hypergamy right
there could be other reasons what are
the other reasons um
i don't have any more kids right let's
say my ltr wants to have kids
okay see you later that's an
incompatibility
but you can talk about that
what is there to talk about i'm a man of
my purpose
i've already i've already decided where
i'm going and what i'm going to do and
if that's a change of direction for
somebody else
then they can go off and do their thing
right can't you figure this out pretty
early in the relationship like if you
want
to have kids or you don't want to have
kids yeah i think that's a conversation
that you should have early on but i mean
like you're asking for an example of
of something beyond what we've already
talked about and i've just given you one
yeah but that's an incompatibility you
can figure out early on there can be
plenty of incompatibilities you figure
out early on
but let's say you don't have any
freaking incompatibilities and you say
you both chase excellence every year
like why can't you have that happily
ever after yeah
so did you watch a lot of disney movies
when you're a kid
no so why do you have this like
you know notion in your head that it's
like gotta be irene's way like it's got
like
the mold of a relationship has to look
this way and if it doesn't look this way
then it's wrong why are you rejecting my
way why can't you
say that it's possible how do you know
it's not possible
it's hey listen it's completely possible
for a woman to be loyal to a man for
his entire life it's completely possible
for him to
go and smash a bunch of other women and
have threesomes with them and all that
kind of stuff and she'll still be loyal
to him it's completely possible for all
of that to happen
but we're talking about on a balance of
probabilities
you're a smart woman you're educated you
know that means basically 51
or more but on a balance of
probabilities this is how men and women
behave in these general types of
circumstances
okay so if you're basically
i'm just trying to figure out like like
i really value my relationship
and i see us at being together like so
don't do us a part
okay you're 32 yeah
um when did you meet your boyfriend when
where
when like how long ago oh like about
five years ago
okay so you met him five years ago so
that puts you at uh
27 yeah yeah okay so were you a virgin
when you met him
no okay how old were you when you lost
your virginity
18. okay so i mean you've clearly slept
with other guys so it's not like
you know you're monogamous because
otherwise you'd still be with the guy
that you were
you know that you banged when you were
18.
right so it's not like like all
relationships have an expiry date it
like i don't know if your relationship
with your five year ltr is going to be
this year
or in 10 years or till death do us part
but the fact remains that a lot of these
women out
out there today are like i'm monogamous
and i'm loyal you'll have me forever and
ever until death do us part
yeah right but the fact still remains
well you've been with other guys
before you got with him i don't care
what your notch count is you don't have
to tell me but you've obviously been
with other guys right
okay okay okay so um let me ask you this
question
let's say your boyfriend's name is bob
would you tattoo bob's name on your body
that said that was the most like uh
that's the most that was the most
aggravating part of your book reading
that suggestion let's say
let's say your boyfriend's name is
richard would you underneath your breast
right over here like right at the bikini
line where nobody could see it get a
tattoo that says
king richard the lionheart
when when first of all no i wouldn't and
second of all why not because you guys
are
together forever so why not because you
wouldn't do the same or
my boyfriend wouldn't no no no no men
men and women don't follow the same
rules
i'm asking you the question you're
telling me that you're committed to him
that you'll be with him forever that you
love him blah blah blah
why wouldn't you tattoo your name on
your body right there because it feels
wrong to me unless you wanted to do the
same
no men and women are not because it
makes me feel like yes it makes me feel
like
irene this is the lie that feminism has
told women
it you know what's good for the goose is
good for the gander
no men and women are different let me
ask this question let's say
you and i are out and we go to an atm to
go and withdraw some money
and a guy pulls a gun on us because he
wants whatever we got
yeah what are you gonna do are you gonna
fight him no
no who's gonna fight on me right yeah
that's my point men and women are
different
okay
you